Attorney General Jeff Sessions will
testify today before the Senate
intelligence panel remember that last
week we heard testimony from NSA
director Admiral Mike Rogers Director of
National Intelligence dan coates acting
FBI director McCabe and Assistant
Attorney General rod Rosen Stein and of
course fired FBI director James Comey
now jeff sessions who has recused
himself from all trump russia stuff is
going to show up and testify a little
bit later today maybe by the time that
you are listening to the podcast or
watching the show the testimony is
happening or has happened and he's not
going to show up and take Trump down
there are some people thinking this is
when it's all going to explode this was
a choice this was crafted and
coordinated doesn't mean it couldn't
backfire against Jeff Sessions and
Donald Trump I would expect lots of NAT
non answers which are now acceptable
remember last week DNI Dan Coates was
asked by Senator angus King
some particular question about whether
or not Trump said X Y or Z or whatever
the case was and Dan Coates basically
refused to answer and angus King said
well are you refusing to answer because
the White House has exerted executive
privilege and Dan Coates said no that's
not why and angus King said well what's
the legal basis then for you not
answering is it classified or secret and
Dan Coates said no it's not I don't
really have a legal basis I'm just not
answering so not answering Pat is
absolutely something that is now
acceptable for no particularly good
reason at these hearings and of course
Jeff Sessions is going to have to serve
the boss especially because his job may
be called into question because Trump
doesn't really like his enforcement of
the now nullified travel ban and the
handling of the Russian investigation no
doubt about it so you are going to hear
lots of that's unfortunately not
something I'd be able to comment on in
this setting and amber Philips in the
Washington Post outlined what would we
want to know from Jeff Sessions if he
were to answer questions well number one
remember that Jeff Sessions met with
Russians during the campaign when they
were allegedly trying to help Trump win
as numerous intelligence agencies have
since told us if I were
that panel I would want to know are
there more meetings that you failed to
disclose that you had with Russian
officials why did you lie or quote not
remember that you had those meetings
what did Russia want to talk about did
you get the feeling that Russians were
trying to feel you out in terms of
whether you might be useful to them in
some way shape or form number two Jeff
Sessions was James commis boss when
Comey said Trump was trying to interfere
with the FBI Russia investigation James
Comey during that dramatic testimony
last week saying Jeff Sessions was in
the room when Donald Trump said
everybody out except for James Comey not
using those words but saying I want to
just talk to James alone what did you
think Jeff Sessions was going on when
Donald Trump made it clear that you were
to leave while James Comey stayed did
you suspect that Donald Trump was going
to try to interfere with something that
James Comey was doing why do you think
James Comey felt he couldn't trust you
Jeff Sessions and then there's the
recusal which I would want to hear about
Pat which is that Jeff Sessions did
technically recuse himself from anything
from the Justice Department related to
Trump Russia investigations and yet Jeff
Sessions his name on a letter was cited
initially by the White House as why as a
reason why Donald Trump decided to fire
James Comey later in an interview with
Lester Holt Donald Trump said well
actually it was related to the Russia
investigation it wasn't just that letter
from Jeff Sessions in broad Rosenstein
but I would want to ask Jeff Sessions
where is the line on your recusal are
you allowed to recommend firings that
would interrupt investigations into
Trump Russia collusion because it sort
of seems like you're not really recused
if you're recommending those firings I
doubt we're going to get answers from
him about these questions and it does
seem as though Jeff Sessions isn't very
comfortable in this setting he's a long
term long time senator so he's used to
being on the other side of the room yeah
and you remember during his Senate
confirmation hearing he allegedly
perjured himself right yet he on an
unforced error he was asked if any
members of the Trump campaign met with
Russians and he said well I know I
haven't and
that turned out to be untrue not once
but at least twice possibly a third time
and maybe we'll get questions as to
whether even more I wouldn't get too
worked up though because I really have a
sense that we're not going to get much
from this in terms of positive evidence
from Jeff Sessions however just like
with what Jeff sessions with James Comey
didn't answer last week there may be
seemingly simple yes/no questions today
that jeff sessions chooses not to answer
which in and of themselves could raise
more red flags if the Senators are
prepared this could be fruitful not in
what is answered but in what isn't
answered and I'll be watching that very
closely